[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
proposition de loi taxonomie verte le
sénat appelle à considérer l'énergie
nucléaire comme un investissement vert
alors que l'objectif de neutralité
climatique nécessite de réduire de 55 %
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
europe d'ici à 2030 l'énergie nucléaire
est aujourd'hui omise par la taxonomie
verte européenne qui vise à classer les
activités économiques selon leurs
impacts climatiques afin de favoriser
les investissements verts
face à ce constat le sénat a adopté une
proposition de résolution appelant le
gouvernement à défendre l'inclusion du
nucléaire dans la liste des activités
durables dans le cadre des négociations
européennes
c'est le moyen principal par lequel le
sénat peut influencer la législation
européenne
fait notable il s'agit d'une initiative
transpartisane porté par des sénateurs
issus des républicains du groupe union
centriste et du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
dans cette résolution le sénat rappelle
que la lutte de l'union européenne
contre le changement climatique doit
nécessairement s'appuyer sur une
diversité de sources d'énergies
décarbonées
par ailleurs la commission européenne
est tenue de respecter la souveraineté
de chaque état membre en matière de
bouquet énergétique nationale
or le nucléaire constitue une source
d'électricité stables et compétitive qui
contribuent déjà à la décarbonation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de près
de la moitié des états membres
en france elle procure actuellement deux
tiers de notre électricité
dans ce contexte l'inclusion du
nucléaire dans la taxonomie apparaît
indispensable et permettrait de
réorienter les flux financiers vers des
investissements durables
il faudra toutefois convaincre nos
partenaires
en effet si l'inscription de l'énergie
nucléaire dans la taxonomie verte est
défendue par la france ainsi que par des
pays situés surtout à l'est de l'europe
d'autres pays tels que l'autriche
l'allemagne le luxembourg le danemark le
portugal et l'espagne s'ils sont jusqu'à
présent opposé
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse des travaux des commissions du
sénat
[Musique]